hey what's going on it's Bill Burr in a
very echoey room and it's time
for the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday Morning podcast
listen to that [__] Echo
and those will be a Capital Records
whoa
something something whoa
I want to touch your titties but it's
1958.
and I am a [__] Irish guy in an
Italian
neighborhood sorry
then all of a sudden there's a fight
right and everybody starts snapping
their fingers right knives come out and
[__] then I accidentally kill
you know the brother of the Italian girl
I want to bang but then for some reason
later on the musical she still hooks up
with me even though she knows I killed
her brother
Is that West Side Story music that's
that's [__] James Bond all right I'm
not gonna let you guys I just had a
double espresso and a flat white flat
white like my ash
and I'm feeling pretty good about myself
right now you know
for those of you out there who tried
cocaine and just can't handle it
and you get too [__] addicted like
caffeine's you know it's kind of a nice
substitute
you drink if you [__] do two back to
back it makes you feel like you know
[__]
you just have an overall good feeling
before you you you you sort of climax
with the jolt of caffeine and then you
start sliding down the back of the
mountain
you know
like a football season like dude I think
we could make the playoffs then all of a
sudden they've lost three in a row
you know are they packing them in are
they gonna fold up the [__] tents
um
the [__] that I want to talk to you guys
about
oh I know I like what people say I'm
done playing games
they make all that their [__] point
and then they like up done playing games
all right but up until like yesterday
you were okay with playing games
[Laughter]
but today I am not in a playful mood I
am done playing games
you know what that comes from right
that's from having a woman in your life
and their mind [__] you or
you know even worse you expect a woman
to play mind games with you what's she
gonna do [__] suplex shift she can't
do it
you know what I mean
I mean her hips and thighs are made for
carrying children not for [__]
picking up her mate
and [__] imagine if God did make them
like that and they were like those
[__] spiders like the black widows
and the second you busted a nut in them
you know that you just felt that forearm
go under your neck and next thing you
know you're just completely upside down
and then they just suplex you down onto
the hardwood floors
you know you're coming to work all
[__] up oh Billy got laid last night
oh then guys would be afraid to knock up
their women they'd keep pulling out
listen I can't look we got two kids I
can't I can't handle another [__]
you know DDT or whatever the [__] it was
called
um
another [__] polish Hammer to my
chest
I've seen a lot of people out here one
polish Hammer to the chest that would be
it
either that it would [__] knock all
that steak and cheese [__] Grease
right out of them
um anyway
uh I went to the Red Sox on Monday night
took my daughter once a year we go to a
game
we had a great time
and uh the first time I took her she
lasted three Innings you know she's a
little kid this time she lasted five
innings
and uh you know what sucked was It was
kind of raining out because I like
taking the train to give her the whole
experience you know what I mean
and getting off at Kenmore Square and
walking up with the crowd and hear all
the chatter and all of that
people selling stuff you know but um
I just had I just kept picturing like
it's gonna because it was raining like
crazy weather that day and uh like
tornado warnings and stuff down by
Barnstable
I'm not saying it was down that way I
just love that [__] Boston name
Barnstable
I'm going to help you guys with the
Boston accent all right A lot of people
like I've seen
like they'll try to say the word like
shorts in a Boston accent and they'll
say they'll say shots that's not how
they it's short
just say sure like the [__] Seashore
sure sure
all right you just don't pronounce your
shorts
yo put on some [__] shorts It's like
a [__] 100 degrees out
you kidding me
I golfed the other day
and you know I don't give a [__] about
that activity but I gotta be honest with
you I had uh this guy in the foursome
gave me a couple of tips
and on one hole I had the best Drive
of everyone there you know
and uh that was something I I keep
thinking about that I'm like don't think
about that don't think about that
because next thing you know you're gonna
be another douchebag with a set of golf
clubs
you don't really [__] freak me out
this place where I used to work
a long time ago I used to work at
Cumberland Farms
um the Main Place
and I drove by there the other day and
it's completely gone
they knocked down the whole Factory I
don't know if 7-Eleven bought them out
but they knocked down the whole Factory
and uh yeah one side they did like all
the dairy it always smelled [__]
gross over there and then the side I was
on was more like it had all like the uh
the paperwork for all the dairy and all
whatever the [__] they were doing on the
other side and the thing is completely
knocked down
and now they have one of those top tier
or Top Flight
those stupid ass [__] golf things
they're [__] huge what kills me
there's a driving range right down the
street
bring a little Bose speaker and a
[__] cooler and you have the exact
same experience dude the [__] amount
of raw materials you should see this
[__] thing
there's a net going around it I swear to
God you could cover a football stadium
with it
Michael Moore is going to do a
documentary about the three kids
that they made so that [__] thing
together
you know and then when it comes out the
top tier Top Flight guys whatever the
[__] it's called
are gonna be like well you know if if we
don't have three four-year-olds sew that
thing together for the first [__]
nine years of their life I know the math
doesn't work out but just roll with this
it's gonna cost you nine grand to golf
it's like or you could pay your workers
and you could take less of a salary
or you could not give yourself a bonus
a bonus
how the [__] did they get away with that
that [__] [__] blows my mind
that they just give themselves bonuses
they're just stealing from the profits
it's literally Casino the skim and it's
totally legal
that's what this somebody told me that a
long time ago said basically all the
scams
that the mafia was doing
corporations do now in a legal way and
they're way more greedy
like any old dealer I ever met said it
was better in Vegas when the mob ran it
they just can't make enough all right
Bill we get it we get it you know
I'll tell you capitalism is great for
the first hundred years
[Music]
That's The Sweet Spot you know it's like
a band any band you love you know you
listen to them long enough at some point
that you know when it just passes them
by
or a comedian like look at me
all right I'm 55 years old I'm up there
like I'll give you a classic example how
if life has passed me by I posted that
video if you listened on Monday of my
the biplane ride that I took down on
Martha's vignette
and um
I I when I was filming it I was like oh
my God this is like I know exactly what
I want to do
up like a tribute to the AC DC
um that live concert they had right
before Bon Scott unfortunately passed
away
the Let There be Rock which you guys
have to see it's one of the great
concert films of all time
the band is just at the height
of their powers with Bond Scott and then
they just rode that right into Brian
Johnson and Back in Black right
and uh anyway
there's a video when they play
um
the song walk all over you
the bass player Cliff Williams is riding
in a biplane and the drummer Phil Rudd
is on the ground driving the Scarface
Porsche
and
um so I put that music underneath it I
even did the cliff Williams wave to the
pilot behind me
and I posted this thing I was
I mean I knew hardcore AC DC fans would
get it I there was one person who got
the video and I was like what the [__]
there was even like a music producer I
actually responded to him because he was
just going like
the you know the footage isn't cool
enough I gotta put rocking music
underneath it and I just literally wrote
you know as a music producer you should
know what this is a reference to
I tried to shame him and then I was
thinking later I'm like well Bill this
is like a concert footage from 44
[__] years ago you idiot Jimmy Carter
was in office
Jimmy Carter
um so I had to actually post
the video that I was talking about
um and I you know and when I did the
cliff Williams wave I I didn't get the
pilot behind me so some people thought I
was flying the [__] plane the whole
thing was a disaster it was just that
one big flop and there was like one guy
in the text thread that got it and the
other guy that got it was Dean Del Rey
so I think I've officially
I aged out of pop culture like I think
uh in about 1989
you know it's just that anyway
um
I am trying to get into Europe's shape
you know what I mean but have a little
bit of muscle mass you know what I mean
but I am going to Eastern Europe and
those people are [__] those people
are like
next level
strong you know what I mean
from [__] fighting the Russians who
are [__] strong you know those people
over there they like think I like that
[__]
you know I don't know what's going on
over there but like you know there's
something in the water
um and speaking of which I watched this
really uh I watched two really good
documentaries
I watched this one on uh Johnny Manziel
um
and that guy that guy has lived
such a life that at 29 years of age he
sounds like he's in his 50s the way he's
looking back on his life
and and you know
things that he did and all of that it's
really really fascinating
and um
and then just also like his complete
disregard for any rules
where he's just like you guys making all
this money off of me [__] you I'm gonna
make some money
you know they'll give the money to my
grandfather and he'll write me a check
he goes because he's a [__] G I'm
like Ugh
I don't know if that's good grandpa
Behavior I mean he's got your back but I
mean
uh he probably should have been like son
now what are you doing here let's not
[__] this up but
um
anyway it was really fascinating and I
also felt like
amazed I was like I saw him his
sophomore year when they played Alabama
in that Stadium it was the loudest
Stadium I'd ever been in
you know Kansas City Chiefs was close
but as far as College stadiums goes the
[__] fans at Texas A M in the first
half because uh
a m had beaten Alabama and Tuscaloosa
the year before and they looked like
they were going to do it again and then
you know Nick Saban
[__] put the Gary Payton glove on him
in the second half and that was [__]
it
um
but that was the loudest [__] Stadium
I'd ever been in so anyways they were
showing like highlights and all that so
I swatched that documentary
and then also I watched
um
this one Conor McGregor
it's like McGregor forever or something
like that I watched that one
and uh
I mean those those things are just
always
anytime they're showing a fighter get
ready for a fight a [__]
you know trying to make a comeback or
all of that it's [__] amazing one
point he like [__] thinks he breaks
his toe and the guy's like [__]
pulling the thing out
to make it better it's just like they
get the [__] kicked out of them during
camp and then they have to go in and go
fight somebody it's it's really uh
amazing and then they actually show uh
you know
Fighters like dealing with defeat and
all of that which I think a lot of fight
fans really need
to watch so they stop talking all of
that [__]
on YouTube and have a little respect for
both the winner and the loser as like
all of that work
that you put in to fight 10 minutes 15
minutes
and then it doesn't go your way and then
you just sit there going like what the
[__] what do I do like the strength it
takes to [__] go back
and start all over again
um
deserves a level of respect that just
does not exist online in any shape or
form
it's like really
would you walk into an arena [__]
shirtless to go fight some world-class
guy who could beat the [__] out of you
you know I won't even take my shirt off
and the bleachers I'd be too embarrassed
so
um
yeah I did that and then I've been
reading this book uh that Brian Holtzman
gave me uh killers of the flower Moon
and uh I would like to address people
that think conspiracy theory is [__]
and it's like they do this they do that
who is they who is this like I mean who
is they
who is they the same they
they the same day every [__] year
when they declassify
files
from 60 [__] years ago and you start
to see what was really going on
every year they declassify more [__]
now they're like into [__] from like the
60s and 70s
the the Geniuses is they wait till
everybody who did the [__] is dead and
then they Declassified it's like oh this
is what was really happening
you know in every year that happens but
for some people but yeah but that was
back then it's not like yes right now
too right now too
right now too they will declassify a
bunch of [__] when we're all dead
about what the [__] they were really
doing
you know I saw this thing recently about
uh recycling how they haven't been doing
it and how like oil companies came up
with recycling just because it would
make people feel good
to think that they were recycling even
if they weren't I mean it's like
diabolical [__]
and they 100 get away with it and then
they go after like [__] sports
broadcasters who say the wrong thing in
the bottom of the third inning
um
um all right Bill are you gonna make
this point every podcast probably
I have an echo it makes me feel like I
know what I'm doing here
um so anyway
um
Oh Billy elliptical
I've been on the elliptical like every
single [__] day
um
of my little break here and uh
I'm seeing the results I'll tell you
what is really amazing about the human
body is is how it can you can be like
[__] 15 pounds overweight and still
look good in a T-shirt
and you're like you know and you lie to
yourself but what you really have to do
is you have to take that t-shirt off and
you have to sit on the floor and then
look at yourself sideways and lean
towards the [__] mirror and then
you'll realize oh oh I'm not even
anywhere near
shape
a long time ago Special K this was not a
special needs program this was actually
a cereal that claimed that you'd lose
weight if you [__] ate it which no
one ever really proved but
and they were like can you pinch an inch
and it was like love handles and like I
can pinch an inch any [__] wear on my
torso shoulder blade man tits
I don't know what happened to me
so
I'm just gonna keep [__] going here
I'm gonna keep working out and dropping
weight right through the [__] Euro
tour because I always make sure I'm in
great shape when I go to Europe because
those [__] [__] those fat [__] are
always saying that we're fat [__] so I
have to go over there and make sure that
I look good with this shirt on
I mean the bottom line is when you're
north of 50 unless you're cheating
you know taking like uh
you know those those gorilla roids
that a lot of people attend there's a
lot of [__] dudes out there taking
that [__] you know face is [__]
changing
it's it's like making you the bones in
your face grow what the [__] are you
doing eat a salad
laughs
do the work stop [__] cheating
Jesus Christ if you look at these people
that are on HGH that take too much of it
they they look what's that [__] thing
you know the evolution of man where you
start off as an ape and then you [__]
turn into a dude they're going back they
slide down the back side
um
I'm waiting for to drive by one of those
[__] uh what are they what they call
that um that stupid [__] what's that
dumb workout where you have to run down
the street past people at a diner so
everybody knows you're working out
CrossFit
you know I'm waiting for one point like
they open that garage door and they
[__] all the people working out come
running out on all fours like [__]
chimps
you don't carrying like you ever see
Dana Gould imitate a chimp [__]
running around It's [__] amazing
um one of my favorite comedians of all
time by the way
uh that's what I'm picturing that
they're gonna come and running out
just [__] hairy backs and everything
you know eight packs and all of that
um
anyway I'm doing a deal I I just want to
look like a uh
you know I I'd settle for the Keith
Richards body you know I want people to
just look at me and be like did he do
heroin in his 20s and 30s because you
know how those guys they're skinny for
life
right they just have that [__] you
know
I don't know what it is
but I think there's something about
doing smack
in the early part of your life like you
stay shredded like [__] Iggy Pop well
into your 60s it's just a theory I don't
know
um
anyway I found this amazing documentary
called GI Junkies
and it was about in it's filmed in New
York City and it was about all of these
Vietnam vets
that came back to New York addicted to
heroin
and uh not getting help and all this
stuff and uh the two things I noticed
about that video was in the comments
section people were just talking about
how shitty Vietnam vets were treated and
for some reason they don't see that
they're
that the veterans today are still
treated you know they're treated better
but nowhere near with the level of
respect
and gratitude that they should be
none of those comments were there and
then the other thing was the [__]
accents
the New York City accents like I feel
like accents are going away
because everybody is sort of exposed to
uh
the world maybe with these devices that
we have but uh I really [__] miss
that
you know like a legitimate
I remember when I first moved to New
York there was a guy that used to do
this I used to live on the east side the
guy that ran the six train every once in
a while I would get up
and he'd be like next stop toity Toy
Street
Detroit
and I was just like that guy has lived
here his entire life I don't know what
borough but I know it's not Manhattan
and uh he probably takes his train to
the end and gets off
and probably still lives in his
neighborhood it was a [__] amazing I
used to sit there with a smile on my
face listening
he called 86th Street 79th was it 70 I
still remember 59th 51st
42nd deity toy 23rd Street
and it was like asked you and your
Square then ask your place or something
like that and then I get off and walk
over to the cellar I used to love when I
would get that guy or you get like a
[__] old-school cab driver
that had like an accent but check it out
it's um
it's called GI junkies and it was
I mean what's amazing is in the end of
it it's like a bunch of Vietnam vets
in a circle in a therapy thing and they
let them film it and the Vietnam Vets
are trying to help this other Vietnam
vet and you just see how far therapy has
come
and uh
they're just like yelling at the dude
how does it make you feel though you're
not talking about your [__] what's it
like yelling at them
like adding to like the trauma but you
know they didn't know any better back
then oh [__] is my phone gonna die oh
geez there
let me see if I have any reads here for
this week but check that out it's on
YouTube uh it's amazing
um
but like really listen to the uh
the accents it's funny is the black
dudes in there a couple of them that
keeps you go you understand
you understand what I'm saying and I'm
like did that morph into you know what
I'm saying
and then it morphed into you heard
and then that morphed into you feel me
you know
I was talking about that the club soda
Kenny we were trying to like the
evolution
of that like slang like they could do it
like with white dudes like let me tell
you something to say
like what did C become I don't have the
brain power to figure this out oh here
we go here's the uh
is the [__]
race for the week oh look who it is
everybody and no Chino looking shop all
wedding season long shouldn't be
expensive with a custom fitted suit from
indochito
that's my thing I want to be [__] as
skinny as Conor McGregor but he's
[__] shredded when he walks around in
those suits uh you'll create a Priceless
memory without costing a fortune
customize every detail on your suit
shirt dinner jacket and more in a range
of colors from a traditional black or
gray to burgundy or Olive
I think I'd Crush an olive soup uh to a
classic Hemsworth Navy
every suit is made to your exact
measurements and you can customize every
detail create a suit that fits you and
your style perfectly with options for
Fabrics lapel shape custom Monograms
statement Linings and more they also
have tuxedos starting at five seven and
nine why rent when you could buy a
custom tux you can re-wear for years to
come indochino offers custom fitted
shirts casual wear and more get a
superior wardrobe personalized to your
style and taste without the luxury price
tag they're always adding New pieces and
options so you can stay on Trend and in
style explore their relaxed yet refined
approach to Spring suits with their new
spring Fabrics RSVP knowing you got the
perfect look all wedding season long
from indochino go to indochino.com and
use the promo code bird to get 10 off
any purchase at 3.99 or more that's
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot com promo code burn
all right that's the reads all right I
did 27 minutes my phone's gonna oh no it
isn't gonna die
the [__] was I looking at I can keep
running my app over here oh geez
um
anyway so to reiterate I was not flying
the biplane the reason why I put that
music underneath it it was a nod it was
a deep cut but I thought there was
AC DC enough AC DC fans out there that
went all the way back so your homework
this week is to watch GI Junkies
you don't have to do this the Johnny
Manziel documentary
the Conor McGregor documentary
and um
the AC DC Let There be Rock you don't
have to do any of that [__] but I though
those are all I give all of those five
stars
all right five freckled Stars
um anyway Pat's got a pre-season game
you know I look about the Pats this year
nobody's talking about them
it's all Aaron Rodgers this Josh [__]
uh what's his face Hamilton what the
[__] his name not Josh Hamilton Josh
[Music]
the the [__] mountain of a man with
the boy face
he's got the face of an eight-year-old
boy from like a claymation thing you
know he looks like Davey from Davey and
Goliath
if he did HGH
[Music]
I mean because he's Josh Allen
okay
and that's that's that's what's on my
calendar the first [__] weekend
is that Monday night game I told you I'm
gonna keep saying it Aaron Rodgers
brings the Jets back in New York City
classic fourth quarter Drive
you know
wins the game on the final play
all the Jets are like yeah we got our
guy all those off track bet and [__]
loses that root for the Jets are all
[__] excited their shoulders finally
come back their head comes up a little
bit
you know and then Josh Allen meets him
in the middle of the field and Nodge
says good game old man I'll see you in
November whenever they play him again
and then I think Buffalo wins that one
and I think it's going to be really
entertaining
and I think they're going to beat the
[__] out of each other and then
meanwhile the [__] dolphins are
laying in the weeds
and then you got the pets right
everybody disrespecting Bill Belichick
they're not talking about him at all oh
maybe we got some weapons from Matt
Jones to throw to maybe we got a little
more protection I like our defense I
like you know what I think the fact that
we just have an offensive coordinator
this season
is going to pay some dividends
by the way the right fielder who's the
right fielder for the Kansas City Royals
that kid played an amazing game he ran
down a Tristan Cassis [__]
shot that I thought was going to go into
the first row of the seats and I thought
that kid was too shallow he ran it he
got on his horse as they say
and just in stride just reached up
caught it like it was a routine
and uh and then his arm
um somebody hit one into the Gap and I
was like oh my God is that gonna be a
triple is that gonna be a triple this
guy [__] got this ball
threw it over the cut off man no bounce
right to the second baseman it arrived
right as the runner did the runner was
standing up but it was actually close
and he made a couple throws like that it
reminded me you know Dwight Emmons
anytime you're in Fenway Park you see a
great throw I mean you got to be
thinking Dwight Evans am I crazy
um
anyway so that's it uh I got two big
shows this weekend I'm in Springfield
Massachusetts and I am in uh Halifax
Canada Oh Canada
you're no better than we are
get off your high horse
evidently black people invented hockey
Indians created [__] lacrosse
so all you did was make syrup sorry all
right um
that's it all right that's the podcast
we will have a bonus half hour of uh a
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast
um right after the Amazing Music picked
out by Andrew Thomas all right that's it
go [__] yourselves have a great weekend
you [__]
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday August 10th
2015. how's it going how are you
what are you doing huh what are you
doing
it's Monday
to get through it are you listening to
it on the way home on the way there
I put it up earlier this week or at
least I tried to I have my brand new uh
I switched internet carriers because I
just wasn't getting any it's taken me
forever to upload these podcasts and I'm
all psyched now so I got this new
[__] internet right it's such a
racket
you know my old internet sucked in every
room in the house my new internet is
unbelievable in the living room and you
can't get any connection anywhere else
nowhere else will [__] let you on and
it's frustrating but uh but whatever I
uploaded my Thursday podcast it uploaded
in like 17 seconds
and it usually was taking me like a half
hour to upload 30 [__] minutes
um just because where I live there's
there's you know
to low signal which evidently isn't a
bad thing because I just ran into this
[__] lady
and she was telling me all this [__]
about [__] electromagnetic [__]
passing through you [__] head
and was telling me yeah yeah turn off
your router every night
give you your body a chance to get rid
of all of this [__]
and uh
who the [__] knows you know I guess when
she was trying to claim it when you when
you sign
that [__] Apple agreement there's
something that you never read you just
sign it that there's something in there
that basically says yeah if this laptop
gives you ball cancer or [__] brain
cancer with the phone you can't sue us
and all of that type of [__] which is
totally believable because all they got
to do is just push that through Congress
and none of those [__] make any money
and they need the money of the rich
people so they go hey you want to
[__] still be in office well do you
you still want that side piece in your
own private Subway over to the [__]
thing there under the capitol for the
past this goddamn bill
and they go all right
that's why we have [__] income taxes
why we have all of this [__] shits
why I love Donald Trump
during that Republican debate he
actually have to [__] you [__] told me
I should be walking around with tinfoil
on my head he [__] said it during the
debate he goes you give a politician
money they'll do whatever you want and
he goes I've given everybody money up
here on this panel and there was like 10
guys and only one guy goes you didn't
give me anybody
it's [__] hilarious
they'll do whatever you want so they go
well what'd you give to the clintons for
what did they want he goes I wanted
Hillary to go to my wedding and you know
what the [__] showed up
she [__] showed up
so there you go I don't know what the
[__] that has to do with routers but I
feel Vindicated all you [__] forever
was sitting there telling me that I got
my [__] uh my tin foil hat on because
I didn't think it made a bit of
difference
whether you voted in a [__]
Republican or a Democrat because you
know those [__] [__] got enough
money to put money on both horses so
this shit's still getting pushed through
right that's why when they go on the
[__] debates they don't talk about
the population problem they don't talk
about genetically altered food they
don't talk about [__] anything
Running Out of Water they know all they
talk about is [__] broads getting
jobs and education and [__] uh
and whatever whatever the [__] we're
doing over there
and supporting the troops
you know what I mean
hey am I out of my [__] mind here
didn't we defeat Germany in Japan in
like three and a half four years it's
like four and a half years
along with the Italians and whoever else
was with the [__] uh Germans
right we got that [__] we got a World
War we got a [__] world war done
collectively when the [__] did it start
39 40 was over by 45 five years we got
this [__] over with
what are we doing now we're over there
with these [__] [__] all they got is
a jungle gym
15 years into this [__] 14 [__] years
into it
you know what it was what the World War
II was we had no intentions of taking
over the country and staying there
that's what it is we have an occupation
going on here so what are you gonna do
you're [__] there you know you're
over there trying to build the Starbucks
you know put up a Staples
you know
you're just going to be constantly
engaging With the Enemy over there
I don't know man
where the [__] do I get off talking
about something that big
you know why because it's my podcast
what are you gonna do about it I'll tell
you you're gonna sit right there and
you're gonna [__] listen to it
I don't know you shut it off I don't
give a [__]
um
anyway so I finally have some good
internet never deadly uh because I went
from point
three zero megabytes per minute signal
now I have like 300
per minute now I could upload a podcast
in two seconds but I'm probably gonna
[__] die in like a year and a half
from the [__] beam that's coming from
the thing that floats over your house
out there in space right the satellite
how come [__] uh Steve Jobs died of
cancer pancreatic cancer you know what
that was from right all those years of
having that laptop sitting on his
stomach
he was trying to beat old Billy Gates
right there he is having to sign the
[__] agreement this might give you
cancer and he go you got [__] he got
killed by his own monster
it's like one of those Frankenstein
movies right
[__] laptop picked him right up and
threw them right in the lake and old
Stevie couldn't swim could he
nope they had those great New Balance
just weighing them down took them right
down to the bottom of Lagoon
died an angry man from what I heard
where'd you hear that built by some guy
who didn't [__] know him
that's why I hear most of my [__]
um anyways so I have not boozed oh God I
miss it oh I miss it so somebody gave me
the green light to boost too I was like
well you know I'm not an alcoholic but I
was definitely drinking like one and
this person was like well I came from a
family of Alcoholics when you drink does
it get in the way of your life because
your life you're not able to function if
you don't have it I was like no she goes
you're not an alcoholic I was like that
was [__] great
can you do that the next time I get fat
can you tie your shoes yeah well you're
not fat okay just keep eating a banana
split
who the [__] orders a banana split past
the age of like six or seven
are you out of your [__] mind what do
you why don't you just stick a gun in
your mouth
spin the barrel and pull the trigger
[__] banana split
you know what's funny about the banana
split that back in the day that was like
you ordered every flavor of ice cream
you know back in the day there was
vanilla strawberry and chocolate that
was it and he got it from the farmer
down the street and there was no [__]
electromagnetic [__] flying through
your [__] head as you sat there you
walked in
right
when you were like uh Hey Clem
hey oh yeah yeah give me all of them
give me a scoop of everything I'm gonna
pay you [__] mortgage tonight by
ordering three scoops of [__]
pay your mortgage for the month by
owning three scoops of [__] ice cream
no no only one banana split in half
sticking up both sides like a banana
[__] ice cream sandwich oh doesn't
that sound delicious I'm hallucinating
that I I for this July 5th I haven't had
any chips I mean any [__] ice cream
no cookies no cake no [__] fast food
no nothing
and I'm in great shape and you know what
I'm bored I'm bored I missed the highs
of sugar the lows of the salt coming
back down right we want to thank you for
flying we know you have a lot of choices
out there right you should [__]
shoving the salt in after you when you
went through the stratosphere with the
sugar
get too high like [__] Chucky
what do you do then huh you open up a
[__] bag of jacks
you stick that orange [__] right down
your [__] throat don't you
coming in for a landing
people please refrain from standing up
um I don't know what the [__] I'm
talking about either don't feel lost
all right
so anyways I had my way in today
all right and I needed to be 174
174 and I weighed in and
173.6 oh freckles
is [__] killing it I have lost 13
pounds on the nose Dan Marino number 13
Ken lindsman number 13.
I don't know who else was number 13
whatever there's two people
um
13 [__] pounds 13 pounds and I'm
actually uh finally um people are
starting to go hey you're losing weight
that's how [__] fat I was
I had to lose 13 pounds just to kind of
be out of shape you know my man titties
are going away you know
I got a little belly
you know what I mean like yeah yeah I
have like a like a [__] let me see a
rack not a raccoon a squirrel
goes out and eats a whole pumpkin and
sits there with its [__] belly all
distended that's what I look right now I
look like a [__] squirrel lady in a
pumpkin
and you're like Bill why did you come up
with that because I saw it
I [__] saw a squirrel after it did it
it was [__] sitting there
the big distend I got I got trucker
belly
but it was adorable that's the kind of
stomach I have right now
um
so anyway son Jesus Christ I got what I
gotta do I I got another what was my
goal 162.
I'm going down low this time I'm getting
[__] skinny then building back up
with the muscle right then I'm coming
back on the booze and I figure by the
end of the air I can be over two bills
that's good for you hot
um whatever I'm psyched to be back down
to this goddamn weight
I feel but I am in I am in uh remember I
was telling you guys like the different
shape
there's uh
with a jacket on in shape
right jack it off in shape button-down
shirt shape
uh button down tucked in shape
they say sport coat in there somewhere
there's a sport coat after the jacket
there's a sport coat then there's a
button-down shape then there's t-shirt
untucked shape that's where I'm at then
this tucked in t-shirt then there's no
T-shirt and then the granddaddy of them
all sitting down no shirt on still of a
flat stomach the only thing you have is
those little [__] wrinkles because
you know
if you actually reach up to get some
cereal you don't want the skin to tear
you need like you need it for when you
reach
anyways
any [__] waste uh
all right so what should I talk about
next oh
rest in peace Frank Gifford man I'm
actually really sad about that I'm not
even gonna lie to you man that guy was
uh
he was a [__] man he had such a great
voice I mean he was part of basically
you can't see he replaced uh Keith
Jackson
replaced him on Monday Night Football
and Keith Jackson
Dandy Don Meredith and Howard Cosell
there's never been a better announcing
team at least in football as far as I'm
concerned and I just remember being as a
little kid
when my dad would actually let me stay
up and watch at least the first quarter
came on at nine o'clock at night so I'd
get to stay up till like 9 30 9 40. when
they would start that show
and Frank Gifford I mean Howard Cosell
would be doing the highlights that's
where I got that thing when I was still
doing the DraftKings thing because of
that man right there I read the no James
Simpson right he gets you all [__]
amped up
for the [__] game and then they'd
immediately
come back
with Frank Gifford who just had the best
[__] voice ever
and then Dandy Don would sing a song it
was just it was the best man it was the
best they always seemed like they
went out and got some drinks afterwards
it's just uh
well who's kid no the kind of men that
hipsters have been making fun of
relentlessly and nerds have made fun of
for whatever just basically the guy's
guy for one for whatever reason the
guy's guy
is uh I don't know I guess because most
writers are nerds so they resent the
guy's guy because when they walk into
the room they've never held Court I
guess I don't know what it is
not saying I'm a guy's guy but I would
[__] love to hang out with those guys
and I would shut the [__] up when they
told stories
you know
I don't know it just seems like every
[__] commercial now is if there's a
guy in it right if he's not being a
complete [__] with some woman rolling
her [__] eyes it's always like some
guy out in the woods
and he's like [__] uh you know got a
bear and a headlock and chopping down a
tree with his foot just this overly
ridiculously manly [__]
that's annoying to me that's something
to Aspire to to be an Outdoorsman you
know be out there in the woods see
something big and furry and [__] take
it out you know like that dentist did
when he went over to Africa I mean say
what you will it takes a lot of balls to
smuggle a [__] lion's head out of
Africa doesn't it
as a dentist the [__] do you get off
doing some CIA [__] like that you just
got done doing a [__] composite on
Friday on Monday you're coming back with
a lion's head
it's incredible I don't I don't condone
it I'm a big fan of [__] animals
which is why you know at the end of the
day with all these electromagnetic
fields taking a bunch of people out in
the future that really doesn't bug me
you know
it doesn't bug me we gotta it's time for
us to go it'll at least like thin The
Herd
right maybe these corporations are doing
a good thing they're [__] they're
making like a uh Corporation raid
you know kills bugs dead maybe go punch
in oh my God can you imagine the [__]
nerds that are gonna be dropping
you know
full amount of [__] nerds that are
gonna die and then Jesus Christ then
what are we going to do
go back to the [__] Stone Age you
need nerds just like you need the guy's
guy
right
you gotta have somebody out there doing
extra manly [__] you know it kills me is
the amount of people that are making fun
of Frank Gifford he had one [__]
affair
you know if he had more than that [__]
you you walk a day in his [__] cleats
being the star [__] halfback
you know
the New York Giants he played in the
greatest game ever played against the
[__] Colts you won a championship you
played for USC
you know yeah high school football team
I mean football stadium in Bakersfield
California is named after you
let's see you handle that [__]
those beautiful women throwing
themselves at you you know Kathy Lee's
giving you [__] about where you're
putting your shoes and all of that then
you go out and there she is
batting her [__] eyes at you
you know
you walk a day in those [__] things
you [__] don't do anything
then you can judge Frank until then you
shut your [__]
ringless Championship fingers
championship ring list fingers I think
that's how I'm supposed to say it
um anyways yeah so that's it they're all
gone Keith Jackson is the last one and
this is all making me feel very very
[__] old
this whole Changing of the Guard man all
of these guys Vin Scully Keith Jackson
Frank Gifford Howard casell all these
guys
you know as these new guys these snarky
[__] [__] who come in and sit there
taking the piss out of the [__]
athletes that ESPN thing which was kind
of funny at first
when they made the highlights kind of
funny but I don't like it now
you're a nerd that's why you're behind a
desk that guy's an athlete and he's
better than you and you want his life
quit taking pot shots at him when he's
not around
and I can say that because I never take
pot shots on athletes
on this podcast yes I do I've done it
all the [__] I'm a [__] hypocrite
what do you want for me
well Bill we'd like a quality podcast
every once in a while oh will you stop
with the hurtful [__]
all right what am I doing here let's
let's read some advertising here
see how long these people last
um all right
well we got a new Advertiser this week
well God knows some slots have opened up
all right all right there we did it we
got through it
it's over
um
so anyways oh you know what I get
finally [__] gave in to
um Jimmy Page for like the 50th time
since John Bonham has died has figured
out a new way to repackage the same
[__] 1011 albums that they made and I
bought all of them
every [__] time and this time I was
like you know what
[__] you
Jimmy Page I'm done
I'm done with you coming up with the
same bag of [__] goods and it just
putting a different [__] wrapper on
it and then you know will still never
was saying never before seen photos and
all of that [__]
um so I ignored the first one I ignored
the second one and now the final one
came out Led Zeppelin presence
Led Zeppelin in through the outdoor in
Led Zeppelin Coda and I guess the coda
one has been getting some rave reviews
so I finally said [__] it and I went
down and I bought all three of them but
I didn't buy the Box thing that came
with a booklet listen never seen before
photos but 99 of them have already
[__] seen
you know
and uh I haven't had a listen to it yet
but I went down and bought those I
didn't get but I didn't get the whole
big [__] thing with the CDs and all
that goddamn horseshit
um and Jimmy promises this is the last
time that he's gonna repackage this [__]
and uh I did pretty good this time I
only bought
I only bought like one
one issue of it I know it's one of them
they won't like the very you know the
that hey hey what can you do like it's
still obscure it's like you can listen
to that whenever you want on the
internet and it's also you [__]
release that
on some box set I remember in the 90s
the one that had the [__] shadow of
the Zeppelin
over the corn fields right
isn't that what happened
I don't [__] know I don't know but um
I've been playing drums like a [__]
maniac and I've been taking lessons
trying to work on my technique and it
turns out I was doing everything wrong
so literally today I'm learning how to
hit a [__] snare drum
something I've done probably a hundred
thousand times in my life thinking I was
doing it correctly and um
anybody who plays drums
if you ever get a chance to just break
down everything that you do it's [__]
amazing
um
this teacher I have and he was showing
me all this stuff where uh
just even like where I was hitting the
shaft of the stick on the hi-hat I was
hitting it where it was starting to tape
her so I wasn't getting it was getting
more of a tinny sound and he had me move
it up that was night and day
the molar method of just my arm totally
[__] relaxed getting a better sound
and then today
he was showing me something I was
playing something on the bell of the
symbol and because of the way I was
holding the stick like whenever I hit
the Bell he could hear the Bell but it
never sounded good but now because I
wasn't choking the [__] out of the stick
like the stick has a different sound
and so it makes a difference no it makes
it more like it's like a brighter
it was like I was chill I was choking on
the stick which was choking off the
sound of the symbol all the drums and
all of that type of thing and I would
get [__] blisters and [__]
um and I always thought oh I haven't
played in a while so I got blisters like
no you dope you're holding your [__]
stick wrong
so
um
I don't know so I'm gonna just
just do that like 15 times a day it's so
it'd be like if you drove a car for 20
[__] years and all of a sudden
somebody showed you a different way to
drive a car
and if you want but if as you got behind
the wheel be totally uncomfortable and
you couldn't drive it as well as you
could
and the temptation to just go back to
the other [__] way
is uh is is the is the biggest battle
out of all of it but uh I am going to uh
I'm gonna stick with it and um
as I as I as I do with [__] you know I
try to stick with [__] once I start to
learn speaking of that man I think all
my shit's gonna come this week
for me uh for the Big Green Egg and I'm
finally gonna try and smoke something
[__] it up and then fix it so I'm gonna
get the smallest pork shoulder maybe
I'll just get some ribs
and I'll try smoking those [__]
things just see if I can actually get a
uh
a uh
so I'm able to keep it at a certain
temperature I don't I still don't get
how you [__] do it I've watched all
these goddamn YouTube videos actually
was on PBS today watching a barbecue
show
uh by the way PBS unbelievably
underrated PBS it's like you watch
something and then they show upcoming
programs it's like I want to watch all
of that
that all seems cool
so
um
anyways but you know something I'm all
over the [__] map today speaking of
Frank Gifford which I was like 20
goddamn minutes ago
um
football season
how far away is it now it starts in the
second week of September is that what
the [__] it is I have no idea all I know
is Tom Brady comes back in the fifth
week nice and rested nice and pissed off
so I'm [__] excited about that I know
college football starts I think like the
first week maybe
of September
um I was sitting there [__] looking
for something to watch today
I watched uh
a couple seconds of the WNBA and I was
like all right let me find a baseball
game
which I couldn't find
because I don't have the MLB package
um so there's no game on when I turned
it on so then I I watched a whole thing
on that that that 13 year old girl that
pitched the Little League World Series
watched something on her then I went
back to the WNBA and then there's just
next thing you know I'm watching like a
[__]
how to smoke meat on PBS
because there's absolutely nothing going
on maybe that's why they're doing all
this Tom Brady [__] it's just like
completely [__] a slow news day
nobody knows what the you know
like what do you do
[__] I I'm like the amount of others
maybe that's why I'm doing all this [__]
learning I play drums taking the [__]
uh auto rotation class all of that [__]
I'm getting those things down everybody
the 180 autos
get it done I know you guys don't give a
[__] about any of this let me uh hear
something for you I bought those [__]
Zeppelin things on on vinyl and I want
to tell you guys that the reason why I
buy vinyl is because I just think it
looks cool it's nice you can actually
see what the album cover looks like you
can hold it in your hand you know
it doesn't you know all of a sudden have
a little Cloud next to it and then I
gotta buy it again or something crashes
I like that but I'm I'm gonna be the
first to tell you I cannot tell the
difference even remotely between vinyl a
cassette tape a CD or [__] digital I
have no idea
what little Steven is talking about and
all these [__] rock stars that are
saying that I'm not gonna be that guy
that goes it sounds better
huh Can can you hear that can you hear
that bass drum pedal that sounds the
exact [__] same to me
same thing with all those reissued
guitars there's a reissued 1959 Les Paul
here's a real one you hear the
difference no sir not at all that's
probably because I have shitty ears
but you know what there's a bliss in
that
you know that's how I can drive a Prius
I drove a goddamn 2008 Prius in traffic
right next to a [__] Lamborghini
today
I did it you know where the [__] he
going
dude if you have if you drive a
Lamborghini down the street you were a
[__] jerk off the only time that car
should be on the street is if it's
driving up to a ramp to be loaded onto a
truck to then be taken to the track what
kind of a [__] [__]
I guess you drive around and just women
[__] drop their panties I guess
that's why you do it
you know
but then by all means don't date don't
date some woman that just runs up to
your Lamborghini you can't [__] date
that you can't what you got to do is you
got to drive around like a [__] Ford
Escort station wagon right and then
start hitting on women
you know well I mean that's two that's
too much that's too much of a test what
kind of [__] a woman wants that
you know they're allowed to have
standards
you know
oh are we built thank you yeah
I'd say drive around in a [__] a late
model uh maybe a Nissan Leaf
okay
let's just drive around
yeah that'd be a [__] interesting
like
[__] prank show
if you had a guy he pulls up in a Nissan
Leaf and he [__] hits on some chick
right
and she tells him to [__] off and he
drives away in his [__] electric car
he drives around the corner he puts on a
fake mustache and a hat and now he's in
a Lamborghini just to see her different
[__] attitude but is that really fair
that's not fair is it
why wouldn't a woman want to talk to a
guy in a Lamborghini
what is she supposed to do
you know
what woman lays in beds going you know
what someday I'm going to meet my prince
charming he's going to pull up in a
Nissan Leaf they don't think that do
they
I don't know what they think why would I
talk for them
do you think Caitlyn knows what they
think now or Bruce now knows because now
he's Caitlyn you ever think about that
do you think Caitlyn looks in the mirror
every once in a while
and it's talks to Bruce
I can't I can't imagine what that must
be like
you know what I mean because if you
wanted to do that right now you've freed
yourself
but then you know what I mean
don't you miss the other person a little
bit
then you have all his [__] memories
you like [__] RoboCop
you know
you stop having like flashbacks and [__]
I don't know
I don't [__] know all I know is I
wish Bruce gave a farewell that would
have been awesome
do you know what I mean
a great time being Bruce
sold a lot of Wheaties didn't we you
know
the one that decathlon
I was on chips right
I had a great time with all you guys I
want to thank all of you
for being there for me this is it this
is a living wake
for [__] Bruce Jenner and then he
just walks off
you get to give him one more standing
ovation
I think that's what [__] me up I didn't
get a chance to say goodbye
you know
which happens when somebody [__] dies
we didn't die he just became Caitlyn
I gotta meet her to see if I can just be
like Caitlyn do you mind if I ask Bruce
a question
or can I ask a Bruce question
how do I phrase this without getting in
trouble with you
um
glancing down at her feet you know
see if he can [__] see all those
years of running track and field down
there you know
I think Caitlyn goes with a closed toe
shoe wouldn't you
for his hammer toes you can't do all
those events without having [__] up
feet you know what I mean
I mean Jesus Christ if you danced in
Wicked on a rage stage for [__] Five
Seasons your feet are gonna be [__] up
for life that's a goddamn musical this
guy this guy he want a [__] decathlon
Jesus Christ
there's gotta be some [__] up [__]
whether he's got the most [__] up feet
basketball players tennis players
oh by the way I'm reading this Andre
Agassi uh
autobiography that somebody gave me man
it's [__] unbelievable Jesus Christ
I'm only like
like the first 60 pages
he had one of those dads that just
decided that that it's like hey guess
what you're doing you're going to be the
number one tennis player in the world
and you're sitting there like I just
want to play with my Legos and he's like
shut the [__] up and get outside I built
you a tennis court and then you go out
there and you just do that every [__]
day and you don't want to do it
it's unbelievable what [__] kills me
is he didn't want to do it and he still
won Wimbledon he still won the U.S open
did he win the French I'm not sure did
he did he get the career Grand Slam oh I
think that's time to look it up let's
put this Apple computer that might be
[__] radiating my nuts right now
actually thought for half a second that
if I did get it at least I'd get a flat
[__] stomach how obsessed am I with
this [__] all right Andre
Agassi crushed me when I found out I was
[__] two years old oh and look at
that oh the internet doesn't work in
here isn't that [__] wonderful
oh Jesus [__] Christ
um I give up with this [__]
do you know today I want to use the
calculator on my phone and I don't know
what button I hit it just [__] kept
doubling the number and I couldn't get
it to stop and I kept hitting clear and
I finally I just set the [__] thing
down I went over I got a [__] pencil
and a pen I'm sorry and a pad of paper
and I just worked it out the old [__]
way
and you know what
my my brain and my hand will never be
obsolete
until I die right then who gives a [__]
because I'm dead you know
it's upgraded
I don't get the new one
right
is that weird
everything about that your hands the
same [__] hand that you've been
jerking off with since you figured out
how to do it
is that unreal
you ever think about that you bought it
my [__] hand is 47 [__] years old
you think in the future you can just get
like new [__]
you know what I mean like on your car
how your starter goes after a while then
you got to get a new starter and you're
fine because the car will last forever
if you just keep replacing the parts I
think that that's what they're working
on doing
you know but God knows that won't be
available to us if they ever figured out
how to [__] do that right they keep
it for themselves
this is where the conspiracy theory guy
comes in if they don't have it already
but they would keep that [__] for
themselves all right
and they just keep [__] you know
unscrewing and then re-screwing a new
[__] head on their body like a
goddamn light bulb
you know
then in the future you can pick out
different heads
like what do you want to look like
you know what I mean
you can just try out everything
you want to be looking like a shlub but
you could be like every [__] race
every hairstyle you know
you just keep putting your brain in
there be like getting a new [__] car
every couple of years
who doesn't want to do that
would you do it
would you just ride it out but anyways I
think that they're gonna [__] they're
gonna have it right look because Erica
there you can grow like a [__] ear in
a Petri dish right
they could do that for years
then all of a sudden they stop talking
about it they grow ear in a [__]
petri dish
and then all of a sudden there was no
more talk about it you know those
[__] didn't stop with I bet they
could do the whole head now
think about it man
where did Dick Cheney go he's got all
those problems with his heart right
where the [__] did he go I bet he's off
somewhere getting a new [__] heart
getting a new ticker you know what I
mean like a new crate motor
came in the other day wouldn't that be
[__] awesome then you just keep going
you know what it is is
the temptation to sell that to the
masses
you know all the [__] money that you
can make
because that's what the [__] they're
into right they'd eventually have to do
it and then they would give us you know
we wouldn't get as good as [__] heads
as they got
it'd be like whiskey they'd be drinking
like Scotch like top shelf [__] [__]
and we would just get like you know the
Bud Light aheads
you know Keystone Light
[__] heart or hands or some [__] that
would be like that'll be that's gonna be
the goal in the future to make enough
money
that you can actually you know when you
get your replacement head you can
actually get a good one like a decent
looking one you know
and
you go out you [__] get get a deal or
some [__]
you come into some money your parents
can be like all right now don't go out
there and blow it all on a head
save some for feet and hands in the
future
but Mom if I have a better hand I can
get a better Broad
oh you don't need to do that you just
save up money and you buy the broad
you're with a better head
she loves you for who you are shut up
you think can you see that in the future
I can't
oh I see a future Where Heads will be
sold where do they get their heads well
they grow up
then they'll have like bootleg heads you
have to get like give me you got to have
like your own [__] head Farm you got
to be like it's got to be like
sanctioned by the government regulated
and all that [__]
then Tarzana today a rain on a bootleg
head farm right they had a big [__]
Greenhouse with a bunch of heads in
there everybody running out
um a Denzel placed the [__] greatest
[__] bootleg head dealer ever you
know ain't got nothing on me he's got a
bunch of [__] heads behind him
right and everybody's like well that
[__] movie's just like his other
movie just with heads oh yeah well you
[__] write one
can't
um
what the [__] up to how many minutes is
that I'm just trying to fill time here
it gives a [__]
um all right by the way everybody
um if you'd like to donate to this
podcast
um
here's an easy way to do it that won't
cost you any [__] money next time you
go into Amazon just go to Bill go to my
uh website first
click on the podcast page and then click
on the Amazon link then you're on Amazon
no [__] big deal right and then they
kick money back to me for driving
traffic there it doesn't cost you any
money ten percent of the money I kicked
back to St Jude in fact I owe those
[__] a check this week
um
you know I actually you know when I buy
[__] on Amazon I go through my website
what a cheap prick huh
[Laughter]
I'm becoming that old guy that old Penny
Pincher
um anyway so if you would like to uh
send an email into this podcast it's
bill at themmpodcast.com
all right bill at
themmpodcast.com that's where you send
the [__] uh poster information if
listeners who ordered a southern tour
poster have not received it yet they
should email Bill Burr merch
at gmail.com include the name address
order number Boston tour posters will
arrive within the next 10 to 14 days if
they haven't already all right I know
we're kind of slow with the posters but
everybody else was like hey
we'll send out your posters and we're
going to take 90 percent of the profit
so
I kind of doing it in-house here so you
know cut me some [__] slack all right
and if you really can't wait I'll refund
your Goddamn money all right
relax it's just a [__] poster
um
oh by the way I have a big announcement
I'm pregnant no then I'm then I'm making
I'm making today
um as of Monday August 10th at 9 00 pm
tonight
9 p.m tonight
um tickets go on sale
I'm doing Madison Square Garden if you
can believe it
Oh Billy [__] red cakes is playing uh
Madison Square Garden on Saturday
November 14th
um I'll have I'll tweet out all this
[__] I don't have the information right
now they're going to send it to me
tomorrow morning which is your morning
right now so I'll have already tweeted
it out
and the uh
the pre-sale is going to be tomorrow
starting at 9 00 p.m uh East Coast time
and the pre-sale code is all you do is
you type in larrylegend33
one more time for all you Nick fans out
there
larrylegend33 uh I'm playing Madison
Square Garden and uh they asked me if I
wanted to name the show and I was like
of course and there's only one thing I
could name it
come on I'm doing stand up
and Madison Square Garden
Led Zeppelin
shot The Song Remains the Same in that
building
what do I name my special
come on think
does anybody remember laughter
do you remember that when Robert Plant
said that he gets so much [__] for
saying that he said that uh
during the uh Stairway to Heaven right
he's like in the forest will Echo with
laughter does anybody remember
everybody [__] on him
because it was very topical they shot
that in like 73 or 74. so the Vietnam
War was winding down in the last 10
years anybody with a vision was shot and
killed by a lone crazed gunman both
Kennedys
Martin Luther King Malcolm X Medgar
Evers all these [__] great people got
whacked
and I was a Watergate was going on the
[__] gas prices were going up through
the [__] roof
well petrol is the [__] English
people say
and as well that was a legitimate
question in 1973
does anybody remember laughter but then
you know the 80s came and everybody was
on coke they're like what the [__] is
this guy talking about I'm laughing all
the way to the bank
Bud Fox greed is good
so yeah so that's the name of the show
does anybody remember laughter and I
like it because Led Zeppelin fans will
get it and I also like it because people
who drive by it'll look like the most
arrogant thing ever like I'm saying I'm
the greatest comedian
ever and none of these other Comics are
making you laugh
um so
yeah so that's happening so I'm doing
that and uh I already know what I'm
gonna do
if they let me if they let me I'm going
to rent a drum kit and I'm going to
bring it into that building and during
the day when it's completely empty I'm
gonna [__] plug in my [__] iPhone
and I'm gonna I'm gonna play
to all my [__] Zeppelin [__] Motley
Crew all that [__] that I came up with
and then before the show starts I'm
removing the drum kit because I would
never make you sit through that
during the day I'm gonna have a good
[__] time uh me and Paul verzi are
going to be uh doing it I might add
somebody else I'm not sure yet but as of
right now it's me and Paul verzi and uh
Paul's [__] hilarious he was all
excited about you know because he's the
biggest Knicks fan ever
um
and he said to me he goes dude you know
what's funny he goes I already know what
my opening joke's going to be he knows
it in August that's how much of a [__]
I'm gonna say somehow it has to be about
the Knicks is what I'm guessing
um so anyways let's get into the uh
the questions here and by the way that
it's an unbelievable I can't believe I'm
gonna get to do that I want to thank
everybody who's come out to my shows
over the years and spread the word uh
about my [__]
um so I get to do that [__] thing so
that's a major
it's not even a bucket listing that's
not something I've ever even thought of
ever doing
um
there's a couple that I want to do that
I really want to do
um
is uh I want to do Royal Albert Hall at
some point
in England I gotta do that one because
that's another place that Zeppelin
played although that place really seems
like a tight ass place and would not let
me bring a set of drums in during the
day but you never know they might
you know who knows
um anyways uh all right Frank Gifford
everybody
this is the first question Bill I'm not
sure if you're going to talk about Frank
Gifford's passing do you have a favorite
Monday Night Football involving Gifford
yes everyone that he ever did
um
and of course the person talks about you
know all the women that he banged and
[__] which is really a nerd thing to do
you know don't pick up let me what are
you gonna do he [__] a couple of
stewardesses who gives a [__] so what
are you
you know I hear all these other Great
accomplishments
you know the [__] guy down at Home
Depot can't keep his dick in his pants
Frank Gifford's supposed to be a saint
the guy lived in almost every decade I
think he did a pretty good [__] job
you know
and God can't get mad at him if there's
a God
should just be throwing his hands up
well that's what I get for making a guy
that good
this [__] great hair of being the
halfback playing in New York Heisman
Trophy winner Jesus Christ that's what I
made beautiful women for for guys like
this to go out and [__]
um
the god in my head that's how he talks
you know he doesn't get mad do you think
he really gets mad
like what a Hitler comes on he doesn't
like look at himself like oh [__] up
on that one
I must have made that one on Sunday when
I was half asleep
all right National book day everybody
um actually getting back to that Frank
Giver thing like
those guys were just Frank Gifford
Don Meredith and uh Howard Cosell those
guys were absolute Gods to me Brian
Gumbel
uh Bob Costas Al Michaels
um
Keith Jackson
you know just all those guys I love
Bryant Gumbel and uh Mike Adam Lee when
they used to do NFL 81 NFL 80 and all
that [__] they were [__] amazing
um
I just grew up on all of those guys and
sports I don't know it was it was just
different back then Sports was this
small [__] thing of just sports fans
you know what I mean like the Beatles
didn't play halftime at the [__]
Super Bowl they just had a high school
goddamn band went out there
you know this you know the first two
Super Bowls they only called Super Bowls
they were just called the uh AFL NFL NFL
AFL championship game and you know
neither one of them sold out
[__] unreal like that's how small it
was you used to watch I used to watch
the local news every [__] night
I used to watch uh WBZ NBC W uh the WBZ
Channel which was the NBC affiliate they
had Jack Williams had just retired it
was Liz Walker Bob Lobel
and uh
Bob Labelle would do Sports it was like
six seven minutes that was it he had to
go around the whole [__] league and
if you really wanted to see baseball
highlights from around the league you
would watch uh this week in baseball
or football you'd watch inside the NFL
on HBO when that came out that was
[__] unreal because all the only
thing else you had to do you had to wait
for NFL films to come up with something
so it's totally changed so those guys
were bigger than life who is the guy who
used to be on ABC's Wide World of Sports
God damn it
I was into everything Jackie Stewart
when he would do the Formula One racing
he had that Scottish accent I thought
was so [__] cool
um Vin Scully of course
um and then you had all the local guys
and back then you had all those homers
you know I hate sports fans that can't
stand Homer announcers there's nothing
better than a [__] Homer announcer
it's the greatest do you know there was
a guy I used to do the Bruins in between
periods and he grew a beard and he
wouldn't and he wasn't going to shave it
off until we won the cup this guy had a
[__] beard my whole goddamn life and
I remember when they won in 2011 I went
on the internet tried to find the guy to
see if he finally [__] shaved it off
um
so uh yeah these guys you guys who are
young you'll see it someday the people
that you loved when you were a kid when
they they get old and they pass away it
it that kid yet [__] makes you really
sad but then also there's also that
thing like [__] man
couple more generations and then it's my
turn
whatever the [__] I'm having a great
life
even if I died tomorrow I had a great I
had a great one I did I National Book
Day
dear Billy Shakespeare
of course I used that one today Sunday
is a national book day uh you haven't
updated us on what you're reading in
quite some time any recommendations yes
I'm reading uh the Andre Agassi
uh biography which I think is called
open
and uh it's tremendous and the reason
why I also haven't been updating you on
anything that I've been reading is
because I don't read that much
um
I tell you my wife bought that uh she
bought that Kim Kardashian book of
nothing but selfies like she's really
into like pop culture oh we had that
argument about it
I'm still seeing that book over by the
phone
and I always have to turn it over
I always have to turn the [__] thing
over I just can't it's just
then we just walk by and you watch some
girl like or you know doing that will
they hold the camera up and they try to
adjust their [__] heads
you know
to try to look better looking or or this
is this this angle right here is the way
I look the best
you know somebody should make a [__]
there's got to be a a thread
of just videos of people [__] doing
that [__]
does it Bill does it have to be
something like that do you have to be
such a crabby old [__]
um yeah that's what I'm reading right
now I'm reading uh the Andre Agassi uh
open that's what I'm reading and uh it's
tremendous and I I like reading
autobiographies by people that did great
things which is such a stupid thing to
say because you know we just have some
regular guy that would be an interesting
autobiography if you just never [__]
strived for anything
you know we just did you just did the
bare [__] minimum
he lived in a one-bedroom apartment
he always had like a six a [__]
Miller High Life you know some deviled
eggs in there
that was it he sat there and listened to
baseball games on the radio and you just
stared out the [__] window
you know there is something to be said
about that you're not hurting anybody
you know
anyways you know what I gotta find out
the name you know that time a long time
ago I mean uh
Bobby Kelly and Joe De Rosa made that
short film cheap we were in the we were
in the Tribeca film festival and we did
uh
and we were with this whole series of uh
short films
and this kid
I gotta find out the name of this he
made this great short film
I'll find it out from DeRozan I always
say that I'm going to find out and then
I never do but I'm gonna this time
um
he made this great short film about he
had a a an uncle or his grandfather or
something
and uh he just didn't know anything
about him and he lived a life like that
and when he died he found the guy's
diary he kept the diary
sort of and he was able to piece
together this guy's [__] life
and it was funny because he was like he
didn't know the guy but it was a really
funny
um
I want to say touching but I don't want
you guys to trash me but it was it was
it it moved you
but it was really funny
and I figured what the [__] was the
guy's line
his last words
on his deathbed where that he said
that's it
hahaha
and I remember saying to DeRosa after we
saw the film I go what do you think he
meant by that and Joe said I don't know
but I would give my left arm
to know what he meant
like who says that's it like you know
you're gonna die like what did he feel
that he knew he was going to die in that
moment I got no no I I [__]
prime the pump here I got to get the
name of that [__] thing yeah you know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna stand my
wallet up here on the table when I look
at that I'll be like why did I stand it
up there and then I'll [__] remember
because if I don't you ever do [__] like
that I do
I don't give a [__] if you don't
um all right Trump
dear Billy elect I don't agree with
everything Trump says but I
wholeheartedly believe that he's the
only person that can set this country on
a course of honesty
I'd rather know what a guy is actually
thinking and disagree than to not know
what he's thinking and to have to have
faith what are your thoughts
um
says phone store girl uh oh no sorry
that's the next one um
I 100 agree that's why he even though he
said all that stupid [__] about Mexicans
to just
you know having a white like the thing
about that guy the [__] he says about
Mexicans and stuff like
as [__] up as it is it's like that's
what a white guy who's lived on the top
floor of a skyscraper that's that's the
kind of [__] that's the way they think
now I went to I've been to the Border oh
yeah did you [__] drive by in your
air-conditioned SUV for [__] 20
minutes you know what you're talking
about
I'm not trashing I'm not trashing the
guy like Dude that [__] [__] he said
about the bankers again
I felt Vindicated when he was going like
when they were giving him [__] for
declaring bankruptcy and he goes he goes
I've done hundreds and hundreds of deals
four times four times I've taken
advantage of the bankruptcy laws by the
way they are lost so he's not doing
anything illegal
and he goes and by the way let's not
make out these people that loan me money
to be these innocent little daisies or
whatever he goes they're not exactly
innocent he goes these guys are killers
he's 100 right
100 [__] right having said all that I
mean that money was also put in
to the banks by Mom and Pop people but
it was printed out by the bankers and
it's really not our money it's their
money and they give it to you and your
jobs to get into as much debt as humanly
possible without going under and paying
those [__] for the rest of your [__]
life they are killers
um
but having said that there's there's no
way any one person could get this
country in order
because what would happen is if he got
elected he would threaten everybody else
who got in the other way and no one
would work with him
um
in a childish way and then they would
blame him and then the guys who put the
money behind
all the politicians also own newspapers
and everyone would just smear Donald
Trump and then every [__] [__] who
thinks they know [__] about politics
would be like see it doesn't work
it'll go right back to the way that they
want it
um to truly change any government to
truly [__] change
when it's as corrupt
is we are
in most of the other governments I'm not
just [__] on my country but as
corrupt as we are the only way to do it
is you have to have literally a
revolution and people are going to die
and people are going to go on trial and
there's going to be [__] firing
squads and all that type of [__] you
know you don't just go like hey we've
had enough and then the people in power
go oh okay
all right here's the keys to the castle
let's see how you do
can I have a job if it doesn't go down
like that so
um
but I will say
that guy he says he's a f Donald Trump
is a [__] star but I also liked there
was a couple other guys on the panel I
liked I liked uh Rand Paul
and then I like the uh the older fella
there what the [__] his name
I can't remember but that guy from
Jersey is a [__] dope he's just smart
enough to seem smart but at the end of
the day eat these big [__] roast beef
head he's he's a [__] dope that guy
should not go beyond the state level but
he will
um all right phone store girl
all right Billy boy last week my
girlfriend lent her cell phone
oh what to you
last week my girl lent her cell phone
cause mine [__] the bed you you missed a
word there lent me her cell phone okay I
borrowed a phone on the way to get oh
Jesus oh God here we go I borrowed her
phone on the way to get my new phone
because I had some work calls to make as
they left the house I thought it was
strange because it felt like
because I it felt like we would be
breaking up soon I get to the place and
a young cute chick is working there I
end up getting paired with her
over the other miserable looking losers
working there wow I thought this was
going to go another Direction I thought
you're gonna say you went there and then
she got some [__] up text
all right here we go at one point I had
to hand her my girlfriend's phone
because I had taken a picture of a
number I needed to activate my new phone
when the girl slid the picture slid the
picture over by accident yep you guessed
it a picture of my girlfriend topless
the girls swiped back immediately and I
just stood there I actually didn't even
really react much just kind of took it
all in she looked at me and goes good
for you
oh Jesus this girl's a gamer that broke
the ice this girl was very cool yeah you
think we joked around before and after
the and after this incident
all right this is what you need to do
break up with this other girl
immediately because you already said you
feel like you're gonna break up and you
don't seem upset by it which means you
don't like this girl you don't love her
I should say or maybe you love her but
not that way dump her and get with this
girl all right
and see where this [__] goes and
hold back your heart though for a minute
this girl might be a [__] killer too
she might be uh a stud on the other side
of the fence and she's gonna [__]
break your heart so just uh
see where it goes I'm already saying
that before I get to the end of this
anyways he goes I get in the car and I
realize I haven't seen the picture of my
girlfriend
she never sent it to me perhaps she
didn't like it or perhaps it was for
someone else
what the [__] just happened
wait a minute
you guessed it a picture of my
girlfriend topless the girl swiped back
immediately and I just stood there took
it all in she said good for you that
broke the ice we kind of joked around
before and after the sentence I get in
the car and I realized I haven't seen
the picture of my girlfriend she never
sent it to me oh because it was on her
phone
oh wait
she sent it to somebody else
dude this is like a great movie perhaps
she